and i say digital health is not about
technology it's about the human
experience technology
is the enabler here
to provide an improved user experience
in a more
seamless user experience and more
empowered and insightful user experience
and and i believe that this
summarized the work both as a physician
as a as as you said as a corporate
executive as in later on as an
entrepreneur welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright
excel welcome to another episode of 20
minute leaders today we're going to be
speaking to dr yossi bagon founder and
active chairman of sweet
an internationally recognized leader in
the field of digital health dr yossi
bagon is an active family physician who
founded and managed the digital health
division at klalit health services the
second largest health maintenance
organization in the world
following the acquisition of his first
digital health company yosi founded cure
ventures israel's first digital health
fund in 2013 after witnessing the impact
of patient non-engagement on the
individual and nationwide levels yoshi
co-founded sweech
today yossi serves as the company's
active chairman
dr yossi bargon how are you today
welcome
i'm good thank you good morning and hi
michael and thank you for
this attention and time
of course thank you very very much for
joining me from jerusalem and dr bagon
you have such an incredible wealth of
experience in the digital health space
especially here in israel you you've had
quite you know in a wide range of
experiences from minion executive and
corporate to leading digital health
initiatives that are impacting now
millions to then entrepreneur through an
acquisition
and in investment roles in digital
health space with cure and now uh being
chairman of switch and and watching this
entrepreneurial journey from another
side and i'm excited to sort of peel
your journey and towards understanding
your greater vision and why you do what
you do and and the insights you have
into the digital health space and so
this is going to be a really fun
conversation and i want you to you know
take me back a little bit and perhaps
even begin by sharing with me what sort
of your grand you know mission in this
world is or in your professional life
and then how did the various experiences
that you've experienced how did they
lead to you being to you being able to
enact on this vision
sure thank you michael for this great
question
um
if i want to summarize my work along the
last 20 years in in the digital health
space before it was called digital
health
um i would say that it's about a
patient-centricity and patient
empowerment or in more
a professional word sometimes it's
called participatory health meaning
how do you
create solutions that
truly puts the patient the person the
individual at the center how do you
empower someone to be a better partner
in managing his or her own health
and i think all the things that i've
done and you've mentioned some
as a physician you know
the ability to
not only to integrate the
the information that you know and learn
but also
to feel when a patient needs a hand when
he or she comes into your clinic and
simply hold his or her hand
um going back to the very
basic values of being a physician
through uh
the privilege i had in a
founding and building the digital health
division of political services political
services is
a the largest stealth organization in
israel and actually the second largest
stealth organization in the world after
kaiser and the states
so
it going really they're through a
journey
yeah
so going there through a journey that
you know takes the organization from an
organization that is
that was based on pen and paper
and i don't know if the audience know
but today in israel
100 of the population have access to
their personal health record you can
access
all your
a lab results and imaging results and
medications and hypersensitivities
and everything is accessible through the
smartphone and through the web
and
not only that you can see all data you
can also act upon it in various ways
whether from ordering your chronic
prescriptions without any paper having
telemedicine sessions i'm speaking 10
years before coffee so in 2000 and to
speak today about telemedicine you know
it's it's like you know became a
commodity but in 2010
i said tell medicine
and people ask me tell a who
so
and the
tens of thousands of
interactions monthly that is that are
taking place today
in in in this and all the data is
obviously analyzed at the background so
um
and many times you know people ask me
what digital health is all about and it
again it goes back to the definition
that i just shared with you
and i say digital health is not about
technology it's about the human
experience technology
is the enabler here
to provide an improved user experience
in a more
seamless user experience and more
empowered and insightful user experience
and and i believe that this
summarize the work both as a physician
as a
as as you said as a corporate executive
as in later on as an entrepreneur and
these days
is an investor and and you know both
members in various companies and
specifically suites where i
serve as a as the chairman because this
company
that's what it's all about it's about
personalizing
proactive health care
in
the preventative space
so to prevent diseases before they even
happen on large scale
can you take me back 10 years before
covert this is a topic that is
fascinating to me you know you're in a
corporate you're saying that the second
largest health care provider you know in
the world after kaiser and you are put
in charge to figure out
tell the what tell a who what does this
mean to now digitalize you know our
health records and allow us as patients
to take sort of ownership and be
partners with you
on our endeavor to become healthier and
and and live longer and happier lives
what what is that like leading this
initiative what is sort of the vision of
of this ehealth idea
of you know 10 years before covert when
people weren't speaking this language
what what are what challenges are you
posed with as you're going through this
endeavor
so
you are you're very right with your with
the way that you phrase your question
because it wasn't clear back then
what does it mean to put the patient in
the center you know it's nice words
but healthcare is a very traditional
industry
uh that is operating in a certain way
for hundreds of years there is very
clear hierarchy in in the you know there
is the physician there is the patient
there is the medical team there is the
hospital it's very very clear
and very defined you know who does what
and
essentially
um
technology here
and when i say empowering the patient
and
and providing tools for the patient to
be a better partner in his or her own
managing own health care it needs a
change in the roles because once you
make the patient more insightful
more responsible for his or her decision
making and the ability to make this
decision
it creates a shift in the traditional
roles of
medical teams and physicians
and it part of the figuring this out
was to
indeed understand
how do you make such a shift
without creating damages like taking the
good things that are existing today in
the system and improving them
rather than
you know doing an evolution rather than
rather than doing a revolution which you
know
can be a significant hurdle in in
in a traditional industry
um
practically
uh what we did we
back then again i i we didn't have
a reference to look at
because we were the reference the the
digital health services that
a my team and i built it clelit became
in many aspects a global benchmark
for nationwide
a
deployment of digital health solutions
similar to what we see today with the
you know with that israel is a living
lab
for kovid
ten years i'm saying it in the good
sense
uh ten years ago we were the living lab
for digital health because the system
here is built for you know
relatively quick deployments of
technology in relatively large
uh populations
so we started from looking at
what was done in the
in the banking and finance industry
where digitalization started about 10
years before the digitalization started
in the healthcare industry wow and we
understood how they
did their journey to put their customers
at the center and to streamline the
processes obviously
finance and medicine are very very
different
i will give you maybe one example
uh you know it's easy to say yes i will
present you
i will present you um
your data in in your smartphone it was
the really really early days of the
smartphone not even
but
presenting your data technology wise
it's easy
but doing it
in an ethical way so imagine you know
it's very obvious for you to take for
you to see all data but what if you
have a
16 year old daughter
uh
and
a
you are responsible for her you are
supposed to see all her medical data
is that that simple what about if she
goes now to the physician and wants to
get contraceptives
still you will see her data
and what if she now thinks oh my my
father will see my
my medical data so i will
wave on getting contraceptives
and then you find yourself with a bigger
problem so which data to present which
data not present to whom to present it
this is not a technological question
this is a
ethical question that requires a lot of
consideration you can present the
patient
a a negative lab test meaning something
that is is uh
that is
that requires holding his or her hand
through a smartphone oh you are hiv
positive
or your cancer result came back positive
so
all these things require a lot of
thinking in the interface between
technology
ethics uh
understanding humans behavior
psychology and i think this is what is
fascinating about digital is that it
brings all these things together in the
most
important things in our life which is
our health
i think that you know you're opening up
such such an important and an
interesting conversation because you
know traditionally as we're talking
about you know as i'm thinking about
digitalization more from a naive mindset
i'm thinking great it's simply the
process of taking all this paperwork and
all these appointments i had to make and
now i'm putting them online in a nice
app but you're presenting this whole new
dimension that we have to consider where
we're actually talking about people's
lives here we're talking about
explainability issues we're talking
about psychology and you know a lot of
philosophical questions about you know
how do we present this information and
how do we do it ethically and
responsibly so as as a leader of these
initiatives and having you know been the
leader of this great initiative you know
which sounds like you know led the
benchmark and led the way for the world
to to understand how it's done how do
how do you personally cope with a lot of
these challenges how do you put together
you know this thesis of this is how
we're gonna do it this is the right way
to approach this problem
first i don't
i don't have all the answers and that's
part of the you know
that's part of the building it up
a
different people
different motivations
different things that lead them in life
and the ability
to serve these people is a lot about
listening and listening and listening um
you know when it comes to health care
it's not just about getting the right
answer it's also emotional and it also
goes to your values and a lot of things
that you need to combine
when providing you know a technology
technology solution maybe i will give i
will use this this question to give the
switch example
switch is targeting a improving disease
management and preventing chronic
diseases from the very beginning we
understood that for such a solution to
work on the long run it needs to be
highly personalized like personalization
like never done before because we all
know that it's very important to walk 30
minutes a day or to reduce or to lose
weight and so on or to take your
medications on time but
in practical most of the people
or a large proportion of the people
don't do it about 45 of the people don't
comply with their recommendations to
do what they need to do
so what switch with this in mind what
switchbuilt is a solution that
focuses
on the providing the right
recommendation at the right time at the
right place in the right context
with the right tone of voice
so instead of telling you hey michael
it's very important for you to walk 10
000 steps a day the type of messages
that you will get is hey michael you
have 45 minutes before your next meeting
it's raining outside so maybe take an
umbrella and go to pick up a
americano from the nearest starbucks
it's only nine minutes away once again
the idea is to touch you in a highly
personalized way in a very contextual
way in order to
push you to trigger action so you will
do what you need to do and then to learn
through
what you actually did or did not do
which messages influences you the most
so if i'm going back to what we started
from
this is an amazing example for
participatory helpful you know
empowering a patient to be a true part
in managing his or her own health care
it's about proactiveness it's about
personalization
and it's about prevention
uh
combining all the values that that you
know we spoke about earlier in this uh
interview
i think that that is so fascinating and
and i i love how your how we've
transitioned the conversation from
simply you know this idea of
transparency and explainability to now
this contextual contextualized
personalization for action-oriented
participation right this idea that now
you know where the goal here is by
putting the patient in the center this
is actually means empowering them to
become partners in the what used to be a
more passive process of of doctor
patient and i think this is you know i i
it's exciting to me to think that this
is where we're heading and that and it's
inspiring to me that these are the sorts
of things that you're involved with
which goes back to our
you know conversation right before
starting to record this episode talking
about this this cliche type idea but not
really this idea that really you know
making you know leaving the world a
better place and and doing it through
you know these different endeavors and
and improving people's lives which i
think is fascinating and so dr yossi
bagona i want to go back a little bit
and and understand you a little bit
better share with me you know what what
really fascinated you growing up did you
always know that you're going to be a
doctor and a physician and you're going
to be in this intersection of technology
and health or or were you curious about
other things
so actually you you pointed out without
even speaking about it before yes i i um
from the time i remember myself you know
the the
i wanted to be a physician the
complexity of the
human body and you know the
interface between the physics and
spiritual and psychology and this
amazing amazing amazing
um
i don't want to call it a machine
because i think it's by far more than a
machine you know the more
we learn the more we know how complex it
is
and the ability to touch it in a way
that is meaningful
values wise or the way that you
described it now you know to
influence people's life in a meaningful
way
so that's you know that was a
like a chord for
from the time you know i i remember you
know what i wanted to do as a grown up
um
and and this was a lot influence you
asked about my childhood so this was a
lot influenced by you know the
my grandmother my grandfather both came
from the crashes of the holocaust and
build their life through
being persistent and creative and
and uh i believe this this is something
that you know if you would ask my
children what influence my my life they
would tell grandmother so uh
and it goes back to the you know the
combination between values and
creativeness that that we spoke during
the last 20 minutes right
i love it and
if you had to choose a few words that
would describe yourself
and looking at your other personal
professional journey what kind of words
come to
mind persistence you know i'm i'm sure
that when you interviewed the
entrepreneurs in the past this word came
over and over again
because it's uh
it's a roller coaster by definition and
you need to be
a person that doesn't get to know is an
answer and still do it in a sensitive
way
a
thinking out of the box meaning being
able to connect dots when it up front
looks like they're not connected
um
so so you know
finding creative solutions to
complicated questions or issues
um
and being resilient maybe it goes back
to the persistent thing but i think it
it reflects a different angle it's it's
a tough journey you know and yeah
resilience is part of it
that's why it's not
it's not suitable for everyone
but it's a fascinating fascinating
journey and being in a place that
can truly
influence
uh
millions and tens of millions and more
lives
it's really i see it as a privilege
i love it dr bagan thank you so much for
joining me this is wonderful continue
making a positive impact on so many
people and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you
thank you michael i appreciate very much
the questions and the insightful
interview
you